grab a plate and throw yourself a
barbecue because Reacher is back along
with his trademark one liners he was
stopped by barbecue he died from trans
fats he's funny this guy's funny he does
that sometimes serious in this video
we'll be breaking down the first three
episodes of Reacher season 2 which is
based off the 11th book in the series
bad luck and trouble but thankfully I
can't read so there won't be any book
spoilers we have a whole new case to dig
into but before we do make sure to like
And subscribe because I don't want to go
back back to my old job don't care if
you do this job is it's been over 2
years since Reacher left margrave in the
events of season 1 I am absolutely
bummed Willer Fitzgerald's Rosco isn't
in this season but she did star in The
Fall of the House of Usher which I also
did a video on how's that for some
Shameless self- promotion Reacher has
gone back to his nomadic lifestyle one
which he enjoys because it gives him a
tremendous amount of freedom but just
like season 1 an event happens which
embroils him in a life or death
Adventure pulling him back into the
world of Espionage coverups and peach
pie I steal pie off window sills this
season centers around the 110th
division's special investigations unit a
unit led by Reacher to look into serious
matters regarding military personnel
other than Reacher the unit is composed
of Sanchez Orosco franzy neie Dixon
odonnell Lowry and Swan through
flashbacks we see the day the team first
met bonded over some casual bar fighting
and looked into an invest tigation
regarding missing plane fuel there's not
much we know about this case so far
other than a murdered private named Sims
was found to have a kite marking
denoting heroin from Afghanistan Reacher
tasks resident hotner Dixon with seeing
if their victim has any connection to
this missing fuel since the fuel's
absence could be explained by an
increased load on the plane itself
meaning someone in the military was
smuggling heroin out of Afghanistan
using military planes I can't help but
think that this case connect with the
much bigger case of the season one which
could result in a giant terrorist attack
and the death of Reacher himself the
very first episode begins with the body
of Calvin frenzy a former member of
Reacher's team being tossed out of a
helicopter Francis Neely learns of his
death and The Disappearance of two other
members Sanchez and Orosco which is
enough for her to contact Reacher and
share her concerns now Reacher doesn't
have a phone so I thought it was pretty
cool the way she contacts him is through
a special code using an ATM Bank
statement I also like how Reacher puts
on this I don't like to get involved
attitude but his morals often push him
to break this rule wait who are you
someone who prefers not getting involved
flashback and a flashback pretty soon
Reacher finds himself in New York and
kneed deep in finding out who tortured
and killed his friend but it's also a
bit sad that Reacher's nomadic lifestyle
has caused life to go by without him
noticing guess life ends when you're
away too he finds out things like former
member Lowry died in a car crash several
years ago Calvin got married and had a
child he's missing out on these big
events of his friend's life as neie and
Reacher look into their friend's death
we see they're followed by a Hitman
named copian he's being paid by someone
high up at New Age Technology some sort
of Aerospace company this is Shane
Langston and I thought it was hilarious
when he asked why neie was using Sarah
Connor as a code name considering he
played T1000 in Terminator to who was
programmed to hunt her down and who's
Sarah Conor I don't give a while
investigating Calvin's trashed office
they deduced that what his killers were
looking for must have been small since
they even broke the chair legs off to
see if there were any Hollow hiding
places we'll learn that this item is a
USB drive one which they find in
Calvin's mailbox what are you the mail
police this USB has two strange pieces
of information on it a list of aliases
whose first name all start with the
letter a and whose last name start with
the letter M we're then introduced to
the owner of these aliases a mysterious
arms dealer who travels across the
country using these fake identities I'll
call him am for now you know he can't be
up to any good when he's burning
passports in an airport washroom
throughout the first three episodes
we'll see him travel to three locations
Los Angeles Colorado and Washington and
this dude ain't afraid to cover his
tracks using the smallest knife I've
ever seen I mean that size is perfectly
average right right I also think it's
interesting that we'll see him carry a
comic book in many of his scenes even
telling a kid do you know why I love
comic books so
much is the good guys always win this
guy probably has a superhero complex
believing himself to be doing good as
the saying goes most villains don't see
themselves as villains rather the good
guy and this is probably what we're
dealing with here the second bit of
information found on the USB is a list
of numbers and it won't be until episode
3 that we discover they are specific
dates but more on that in a bit now
Reacher and Neely come back to their
hotel room to find it trashed but even
more surprising is the presence of
odonnal another former member of the
special investigations unit according to
him the place was trash like this when
he got there but I'm keeping my eye on
him because that's quite the coincidence
I have a sneaking suspicion someone in
the team will double cross them and from
the first three episodes my guess is
either odonnell or Dixon in episode two
Reacher and the others will team up with
Dixon as they believe someone is
targeting members of their team killing
them one by one but who would want to do
this is it someone their team put away
and holds a grudge or is something more
nefarious at play following them is nyp
detective Gano Russo his investigation
into the death of Calvin frenzy has put
Reacher in his team as Prime suspects
and it totally doesn't help that Reacher
beats the crap out of him in his defense
he didn't know Russo was a cop until
after this will come back to haunt him
later when he's arrested which actually
Works in his favor as Russo and Reacher
will end up working together to uncover
this plot the next stop in their
investigation leads them to Atlantic
City turns out Calvin was working with
two other former members Orosco and
Sanchez and they were working on
something that could have gotten them
killed we hear from this woman that
Orosco kept repeating the numbers 650 at
100K each leading Reacher in the team to
believe he was investigating something
involving nearby casinos since both
Orosco and Sanchez now worked in
security for them but later in episode 2
we'll find this isn't the case Chief
security officer Wright confirms they
weren't working on any special case for
the cinos but more concerning is our pal
am who's tipped off about a shipment of
650 weapons weapons he promises won't be
used on us soil so it looks like fronzi
Orosco and Sanchez were looking into a
weapons deal between am and Langston at
the beginning of episode three we'll see
Langston torture frenzy wanting to know
how much he figured out and who else
knows about it but the question remains
what does a guy working for an aerospace
company want with weapons and what
exactly are these weapons especially
ones that come at 100K a pop to make
matters worse the team learns that the
bodies of Orosco and Sanchez have been
found each with similar torture markings
and dropped in the same wooded area as
franzi after taking out copian the
Hitman in charge of taking out Reacher
they find a parking pass in his car for
New Age Technology this is their first
clue link whoever is after them to New
Age Dixon and Neely will investigate
meeting new age director of operations
Marlo Burns she claims that this man was
here for a job interview and passes on
to them his address but as we'll see
later on this is all an ambush meanwhile
Reacher is interrogated by Russo I
thought it was interesting how pissed
Russo gets when Reacher insinuates he's
a dirty cop so there might be more of a
backstory there we do however get some
more information regarding am Russo was
able to find an unfinished job on the
memory card in Fran's printer one which
shows am is wanted by Homeland Security
for conspiracy to commit a terrorist act
this guy is an international arms broker
who claims he can get any Tech to the
highest bidder this is likely why
Langston wants whatever am is selling
perhaps there's some technology here
that could be beneficial to New Age
maybe it belongs to a rival company or
it might help him acquire a defense
contract there's just not enough
information to go off just yet meanwhile
Dixon cracks the code on those
mysterious numbers found on Fran's USB
and I got to admit this was really
confusing the first time I heard it I've
understood nothing since you said oh my
God first there are seven of these pages
and each page designates a specific
month of the year Dixon will theorize
that these are the final seven months of
the year so from June to December on
each page there are a series of either
26 or 27 numbers these numbers are work
days if you follow a Six-Day work week
so depending on when your month starts s
you either have 26 or 27 work days in it
with anywhere from 3 to 5 days off I've
understood nothing since you said oh my
God why is this important well these
numbers correlate to some sort of
shipment with Dixon stating that there
are huge number in the early months I.E
June and July with it dwindling in the
ladder my mind immediately went into
drug shipments especially since we have
this secondary case told through
flashbacks which seems to involve opium
in Afghanistan saw these all the time in
Afghanistan now this could just be a
incidence but I researched when the
Opium Harvest starts in Afghanistan and
it lines up with June the same month
these Pages start which could explain
why the beginning months have lots of
shipments and they slowly dwindle as the
Harvest ends but the episode winds down
with the Ambush at copian house someone
wanted them to show up at this address
but Reacher and the team make quick work
of these men while Reacher chases after
this guy who was sent to make sure the
job was done this dude looks like an
office job type of guy leading me to
believe he was sent by Lang but things
get extra weird when Reacher and the
Gang break into New Age stealing hard
drives files and all sorts of
information the biggest Revelation is
that former SIU member Tony Swan worked
there too and he seems to be pretty high
up right next to the head of operations
and Langston himself in episode one
Reacher believed Tony to be dead Swan's
dead as he would never have left his dog
to die locked in his home we can't rule
anything out when it comes to Swan he
could have worked with Langston or it's
possible he was undercover and working
with fronzi that still leaves us with
the question of whether or not he's
alive could he be on the run and what
exactly was his involvement with new age
these are questions for next episode but
now I turn it over to you what are your
thoughts and theories on what's to come
I'd love it if you liked and shared this
video I hope to do more if it does well
thanks for watching for more bad takes
you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember he was stopped by barbecue
he died from trans fat